[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the way that can be articulately
described is not the unchanging way the
name that can be set out loud is not the
unchanging name with your mouth on
opened and things left undefined you
stand at the beginning of the universe
make definitions and you are the measure
of all creation thus being forever
without desire you look deeply into the
transcendent by constantly harboring
desire your vision is beset by all the
things around you these to enter the
world alike but their names are
different alike they are called profound
and remote profound and remote and again
more so this is the gates to all
mysteries everybody understands the
beautiful to be beautiful but this only
creates the concept of ugly everybody
understands the good to be good but this
only creates the concept of bad there
can be no existence without
non-existence no difficult without easy
no long without short no high without
low and without the sounds of musical
instruments and human voices where would
their harmony and cacophony be before
and after only depend on which one
follows first therefore the sage resides
in non fabrication and conducts himself
according to wordless teachings all
objects in the world come into existence
but he does not judge them they are born
but he does not possess them the sage
act relies on nothing he accomplishes
and moves on by moving on he never has
to leave
do not respect the clever and the people
will not be induced to conflict do not
be impressed by hard to get material
things and the people will not be
induced to covet what they lack and grab
what is not theirs
do not stare at the desirable and the
people will not be induced to entangling
thoughts
therefore the sage manages the flow of
their activities like this he empties
their minds but fills their stocks he
weakens their willfulness but
strengthens their bones he constantly
leads the people towards less knowledge
and less desire thus masters and wise
men will not dare to act act without
fabrication and there will be nothing
you cannot manage the way is as empty as
an empty bowl yet when used it never
fills deep and ill-defined resembles the
distant ancestor of all things it blunts
sharp edges unravels their tangles
soften their blazing lights and blends
one where their dusts gentle and
overflowing it always seems to be there
I don't know who gives it birth it
appears to precede the creator of his
home
[Music]